disgraced media mogul Harvey Weinstein
faces four new sex crime charges in Los
Angeles
this comes as jury selection gets
underway today in his New York trial the
LA charges are based on a rape
accusation from one woman and a sexual
assault allegation from another the
separate incidents allegedly took place
over a two day period in 2013 now those
proceedings will not start until
Weinstein's trial in New York wraps up
Weinstein denies all allegations of
non-consensual sex in the New York case
he has not yet commented on the charges
in Los Angeles New York Times
correspondent and CBS News contributor
that's Jodi Kanter won a Pulitzer Prize
for breaking news about Harvey Weinstein
she is here with the new developments
and the results of a new CBS News poll
on the impact of the me2 and times up
movements Jodi good to have you back at
the table listen it doesn't seem like
yesterday was a very good day for Harvey
Weinstein but what did these new charges
mean that they come at the same day that
his new trial is beginning as they're
selecting a jury it was an incredibly
dramatic development and Harvey
Weinstein is essentially now fighting
charges on two fronts and as you said
these la allegations are very dramatic
the prosecutors are basically accusing
him of hurting women day after day in LA
and remember that as jury selection
starts in New York the New York jury may
know about what he what he's accused of
doing in Los Angeles do you think these
two cases could affect each other
Jodi they can in ways that are very
unpredictable first of all there's a
woman who's involved in both cases there
are only two women at the basis of the
New York charges but the prosecutors can
call other witnesses one of those
witnesses is also at the center of the
LA allegation but that's the point as
lawyer was making when we talked to her
earlier that we've hear all these
terrible stories about Harvey Weinstein
but it ended the day this case only
involves two women so he may have been a
sinner she says but he's not a criminal
what do you say about that
in light of all that we keep hearing
about him you know until opening
arguments happen I think we don't really
know the exact strength of the
prosecution or
the defense here's the advantage that
the prosecution has when they begin to
show a pattern that can be really
devastating remember that the nature of
the Harvey Weinstein allegations is
these women who are strangers to one
another who didn't know each other
they're telling very similar stories
about the same man over and over again
that's really powerful what the defense
has on its side is that remember the
jury has to be unanimous to convict when
is the last time that 12 people you know
agreed on these really complicated
matters about sex and power so they may
be able to create some doubt about
exactly what happened and about consent
in the jury's mind I want to get your
reaction to this new CBS News poll on
times up and and the me2 movement a
quarter of people say they are talking
more about the issue of sexual
harassment and misconduct but most
people say things have not changed does
that surprise you
well I think what's confounding now is
that everything's changed and nothing's
changed you know what we see two plus
years later is that first of all people
are still really confused about what
sexual harassment is it's not a criminal
charge like the ones in in these cases
in New York and LA and it's not really
about sex it's about work it's about
women's opportunities in the workplace
and going into the workplace and trying
to do a job and instead being asked for
something else I think also it's part of
why this case is so symbolic because
what we've seen is that social attitudes
have shifted but have they shifted in
the courtroom have our laws shifted how
will a jury respond to this kind of
evidence will they see it differently
than a jury might have seen it a decade
or two ago we'll see you also say this
case is so much bigger than just one man
exactly thank you tomorrow we'll look at
the times up Legal Defense Fund and it's
effort to help victims of sexual
harassment at work
you